las autoridades rusas Han detenido en
ekaterimburgo al periodista
estadounidense
evanskovich se expone a 20 años de
cárcel por andar investigando
informaciones que según Rusia suponen
secretos de estado garrascovich ha sido
detenido en la ciudad de ekaterimburgo
en los urales Durante los últimos días
había estado investigando la opinión de
la población local sobre Los mercenarios
de Wagner que han tenido un papel
protagonista en las batallas de bakmut
en Ucrania
perovich también había estado
investigando la industria militar rusa
en concreto había viajado a una ciudad
donde se encuentra una de las
principales fábricas de tanques de Rusia
ahora mismo Rusia se encuentra en una
situación difícil precisamente porque
están siendo destruidos más tanques de
los que en el momento actual es capaz de
producir